I'm very uncomfortable right now but
nevertheless the plow forward
in a dominant fashion uh
uh the the blog post titled rape
Spectrum survey results
what are the key takeaways from that
survey so I did the survey when I had a
friend be like hey I had this confusing
sexual experience was it rape like
somebody kind of pressured her and she
eventually stopped saying it or
something I was like that's a great
question like I don't know how people
would consider this and so I put a whole
bunch of different gray uh scenarios uh
into a survey and then ask people to
rate how rapey they thought that
scenario was she actually like little
like little narratives
yeah they get a rate like you know this
person is on a date with this person
they get drunk and the other person's
not drunk I try to keep gender neutral
uh
names for all of them and they you
reduce them into a more concise
description of the situation yeah like
in this visualization so you have this
rape Spectrum that's a result yeah where
on top are things that are less likely
to be considered raped by the people
that took the survey and the bottom more
likely
the the likeliest is a stranger forcibly
assaults someone who screams and fights
the entire time that gets a hundred
um what do we make of something that's
not zero it's like a 12 is what what's
that how are we supposed to interpret a
12 out of 100 that's extremely low okay
it's like not zero but it's just very
close to it having sex with an
enthusiastic sex worker yeah is it 12
that's the lowest one and there's a few
I'll just mention a few that are lower
like at that level have sex to make a
partner happy in a relationship lying
about wealth hobbies in order to get
laid
person with Down Syndrome eagerly has
sex within your typical not revealing
being transgender until after sex and so
on I think you mentioned that there's
some like either that not revealing
being transgender until after sex
there's some differences
amongst what men and women or something
like that I think that men found more
offensive than women I'm trying to I
wrote a little while ago
I mean uh this is nuanced and difficult
right it's because uh I think in a lot
of public discourse the word rape is
pretty binary yeah it's like either is
or is not rape and so you had a friend
who was like this felt rapey
yeah she's like confused about how to
interpret it I think people look to the
terms to know how to feel about
something yeah like have you ever like
been through an experience you're like
that was weird and then you tell it to
somebody else and they're like oh my God
you were assaulted yeah and then it
totally recontextualizes the thing that
you've experienced and I think that this
is clunky with the word rape because
either you were raped or you're not you
either like have this entire context
like thrust upon you or you don't and
we're really not nervous about it at all
and so I would really like to have some
sort of like oh that was like a 30 rape
you just endured
yeah and I mean there's probably other
dimensions about how traumatic it is how
difficult it is to recover from all that
kind of stuff
yeah I mean like people it's a dangerous
thing to assign a word to to an
experience like even or to a
relationship like saying a toxic
relationship
yeah that can completely destroy your
perception of that relationship
yeah absolutely I remember this was the
case with my childhood like I talked
about being very abusive but I've talked
about how like there's a good amount of
meaning there so that I didn't process
it as abusive at the time I remember
after I got out of that house in that
culture people would tell me oh your
childhood was really abusive and I was
really confused by that because it's a
total re-contextualization of that
narrative it's like the things that I
went through were not you know good and
virtuous and had meaning but rather
those were like the result of you know
parents who didn't like love you enough
or something uh and it even though the
the concrete things that happened to me
did not change like no facts shifted the
fact that like the the interpretation of
the fact shifted caused me quite a bit
of distress for a long time I was like
oh my God I'm you know I'm a traumatized
like abused person like I went through
an abusive childhood and it was really
hard for me made it worse like it's
crazy the power that terms have